now I'm told that you are uh you are
good friends with Mr Shaquille O'Neal
I've met him many times Shaq has agreed
yes not very nice guy what's what's it
like hanging with Shaquille O'Neal uh
first I don't call him Shay I call him
long knees little body that's what I
call him uh long knees little body Shaq
has the body of a Dutch woman
it's the worst thing I'm talking about
well you've never seen a Dutch woman so
it's undefined that's why that's the
thing but Shaq his men Shack's
relationship is complicated because all
we do is tease each other you know all
his jokes of me being small minds of him
being big but naturally I win because
I'm a comedian he's not but lately I've
been tearing him up man I just hate I
hate the way Shaq falls like that's what
that's what kills me like literally he
falls in steps he's got like a
three-step phone when he's in the game
and he's playing it's the worst thing
ever like have you ever seen has anybody
ever seen Shaq fall I wish I see this
yeah can you show us yeah if this
doesn't look like it just tell me look
okay literally it's three sections this
is Shay he goes for a rebound he doesn't
get his oh no oh oh God no
laughs
[Applause]
his legs are stuck in the air it's the
worst thing ever nobody can help him up
because he's too big so you just gotta
wait you gotta wait he's just there for
a while it's like a it's like a turtle
on the highway
it's like a really fat baby
you can't get him I swear to see that's
like a fat baby with no balance he just
lays on it
I love him to death though that's very
cool that you get now uh I want to ask
you very quickly uh I know you got a
stand-up show yes Laugh at My Pain yes I
do and it's at the Nokia Theater
right here in Los Angeles and this is
February 18th and 19th yes correct and
this is you doing uh stand up and me
don't stand up Conan would you say are
both shows sold out yes they are because
uh yeah
no no I heard him I definitely I
definitely heard him say that I
definitely heard him say that yeah
they're sold out uh colon reason why why
do I even have to be here no no I uh
come on my kids I'll tell you about my
kids uh no no this is a big thing man
we're we're doing something special on
this date you know I'm taping my new
stand-up special which is laughing my
pain does this look weird with my knees
up here do I look too small no no I
don't know
totally hot yeah this is good
I don't
know
thank you
[Applause]
sorry I don't know I don't like my legs
and swings no I just wanted you to feel
comfortable too it's not what I would
have did for Black History Month
I would have put a smaller chair out
here but whatever it's no big deal so
watch for that stand-up show Laugh at My
Pain Kevin hilarious oh thank you so
much thank you guys